because our draft today is this year's
version of the 49ers and it doesn't just
have to be the team that surprises us
there may be some other parallel to last
year's 49ers that we can draw so it's a
wide open palette and we go whatever
direction we want to go and there's no
trivia question so i'm going to give you
the first crack at this one because i
don't know what the hell my picks are
going to be at this point usually i'm
prepared i'm not sure how to do this one
so you go first yeah thank you thank you
so you're so nice to give me the first
pick today you're right i i don't know
where the hell to go with this either
all right my first pick's gonna be the
pittsburgh steelers for this year's
49ers damn it yes eat it you shouldn't
have been so nice but the correlation is
this that's the first time anyone's ever
said that to me
eat it
no oh no that's you you shouldn't have
you're so nervous
yes you're right okay
and the message is up on the screen in
the uk hello london watch out for that
idiot on the right of your screen he has
a bad mouth okay so yeah i go the
steelers one because that defense is put
in place right like the 49ers to where
you're excited about but two
just like last year's 49ers they're
quarter acts coming off an injury from
the previous year and jimmy garoppolo i
believe it was like week three against
this kansas city chiefs you know two
seasons ago of course it was week two
last year for big ben roethlisberger so
that's where i'll draw that correlation
as far as defense quarterback coming
back uh to be you know this year's 49ers
and see i was drawn to the steelers for
that very reason you lose your
quarterback early it's a wasted season
and then there's this just kind of vague
i don't know what this team's going to
be um i'm going to take that concept but
i'm going to mash it up a little bit i'm
going to say
even though they made the playoffs last
year they made a quick exit
i'm going to say the patriots
because of cam newton because he's the
guy who had the last season week two
gone for the year forgotten by the nfl
still questioned still doubters doubters
about the patriots without tom brady
they've got the defense cam newton
proving himself coming off of that
serious injury and this is a team that
potentially could be dominant in the afc
the same way the 49ers were dominant
last year in the nfc so you know i'm
kind of twisting and combining here and
i thought about the panthers because
they lost cam newton last year but
they've lost him for good so i'm not
going to put the panthers in that 49ers
category but i will put the patriots
there by virtue of the fact that they
inherited the guy who left early in 2019
and could be back to full form in 2020
yeah that i mean i i hear you with the
correlation there i mean yes i mean
you've also called shanahan mini
belichick right so there's some
correlation there uh but but
man just from all indications cam newton
has
lit a fire of energy from what i know up
there in new england he has become the
leader of the team
every day he's a special personality and
a special
you know energy and human being about
him and i i think he has made his mark
on that football team already and uh i
get you i'm not mad at you there for for
picking them even though i'm not a shaky
correlation but okay i'll deal with it
all right cleveland browns is where i'll
go next cleveland browns
i think again a little bit like the
49ers
there's some superstar aspects to their
defensive line oh okay hey nick bosa you
know d ford okay well here's miles
garrett and olivier vernon and you know
sheldon richardson in the middle so they
got this front four that i think could
be really dominant up front that way and
the correlation i go here too where's
next level correlation all right joe
woods came from the 49ers he was part of
their defensive staff now he's the
defensive coordinator of the cleveland
browns so he's going to run that scheme
run that system they have long corners
who can play that similar style of a
richard sherman and everybody else so i
look at that but then on the offensive
side of the ball there's correlation two
to where i go it's a team that's going
to be about the run game like you talked
about kevin stefanski was just with
kubiak kubiak learned the run game from
shanahan
kyle shanahan's the master of the
running game in football he is the zen
master there is nobody more creative and
finds ways to gash people in the run
game and kevin stavansky has a little
bit of that in him as well not as
creative but i just think between that
and then yes baker mayfield we're still
questioning him like we were questioning
jimmy garoppolo last year uh that's
where i'll kind of try to throw that
correlation a little bit with the talent
of the team and there's some coaching
connection there crossover
you know i'd really like to cross over
to the nfc since that's where the 49ers
are and we haven't picked an nfc team
yet but before we do that i'm going to
put the chargers in here okay right
there's just this vague sense of malaise
this funk this what are the chargers
really going to be and now you throw the
derwent james injury on top of it so
you're more likely to disregard the
chargers oh it's going to be next year
when justin herbert's the quarterback
when derwyn james is back it's not this
year
but they've got a bosa there's only two
bosses the 49ers have got one of them
the chargers have the other and he's
paid and he's motivated and he's happy
and they've got the interior defensive
line you've talked about picking up
linval joseph from the vikings
uh that the defense can drive this
this bus and that's what the 49ers yeah
yeah the offense with the running game
was really good i think we can overlook
very easily the chargers offense because
we just had tyrod taylor but as we've
said time and again he's got an
assortment of weapons he's never had
before not when he was the starter in
buffalo not during that brief period of
time he was the starter in cleveland and
this is just one of those where you know
they start yeah and we see this every
year
teams start piling up wins
teams we weren't really sure about and
we're like okay well okay
well maybe they are good and you just
develop this sense that really bakes in
by halloween where you're like hey this
is a team that we need to take seriously
all year long and there's a chance the
chargers could have it unfold that way
yeah i i i don't disagree you know and
they yeah i mean they're going to rely
on the running game like you talked
about that's what anthony lynn wants to
do oddly enough they play the same
defensive scheme the 49ers do too
and then they got yeah ingram bosa
linville joseph we forget about their
their their first round pick from the
2019 draft and jerry tillery he's
another interior d lyman so you look at
them and you go damn they got three
first rounders on the on the off
defensive line you know what was the
49ers last year four first rounders so
you know that's you don't hear that a
lot three first rounders and linville
joseph i want to say he was a second or
third rounder i don't know but either
way there's some a lot of quality play
there in that front seven uh so i i'm
hear you there i could buy that too man
i'm really stressed here about the last
pick i don't know what the hell i'm
correlating to the 49ers here i think
what i'm gonna do here
is just go back to the atlanta falcons
and go damn it yeah eat it for yo hey
for part two you shouldn't have been so
nice before the draft started okay so
the atlanta falcons i'm picking them
because
i think this is the first time since
shanahan left that i feel like oh okay
this could be the year for the falcons
hopefully they can avoid the injury bug
there is an issue with them being a
little top heavy as we talked about but
i just feel like since shanahan left i
know they had the one playoff appearance
and lost the eagles in the divisional
round i don't feel like the offense has
ever been quite as quite the same and
they've never been quite as dominant as
a football team altogether where i feel
like this year it has a chance to line
up that way and again it's funny it's
same defensive scheme todd gurley there
is the running back we'll see how all
that goes and of course can matt ryan
have that success that he had with
shanahan uh that's gonna all be big
things here this year but i think
they're one of those teams that jumped
on the scene a little bit more uh this
year as compared to last
i agree with you and another reason i
was gonna pick the falcons of the teams
that are in this category they are the
most likely to blow a double-digit lead
with seven minutes left in the super
bowl which would be another parallel
ah there he is
doctor doomsday that's right at the end
of the thursday draft
that's why i was gonna pick them how
about the chicago bears right here here
we are year three for matt nagy it's
more than year three for ryan pace but
remember going into year three for kyle
shanahan yeah we weren't really sure
what the 49ers had gotten themselves
into and there was talk of dysfunction
between him and john lynch and maybe one
and it would have been lynch on the hot
seat not shanahan but but you know and
and then it all just kind of falls
together driven by the defense akeem
hicks healthy khalil mack much more
effective when akeem hicks is healthy
yeah robert quinn
to beef up the pass rush and the defense
takes over and all of a sudden the
offense doesn't have to be yeah great if
your defense is
and that's what the 49ers story was last
year if the defense is great the offense
doesn't have to be uh and uh maybe maybe
we see them embrace the running game
because they can't figure out who the
hell they trust to throw the football so
i'll go bears yeah okay i mean i get you
yeah defense we know that's in place
you're right
neggy you're three like kyle shanahan we
were all sitting there going oh this is
a big year you know and also we were you
know questioning the quarterback
position before last year with the 49ers
i mean let's not forget this time last
year we were just coming off of whoa
jimmy garoppolo has not been great in
practice he threw five interceptions and
practiced scrimmage against the denver
broncos is he gonna be the downfall of
this 49ers team and not to say we're
having that conversation with the bears
but we're having a conversation about
the quarterback going who the hell is it
going to be and what's this offense
going to quite look like and can they
trust either one of these quarterbacks
so yeah there's some correlation to this
sorry i kind of like this draft it was
so open-ended you could kind of go
anywhere with it uh i clearly won but it
was a good draft
okay you clearly won because
because i was too nice whoa three times
in one segment you're too nice i would
have had the steelers and i would have
had the falcons if i would have just
said i'm taking the first pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports